[Music]
everyone is obsessed with the hit
boyband
why don't we and we can't seem to get
enough of these five amazing musician
stay tuned to find out 20 awesome facts
about the members of the band who
doesn't want more awesome content click
subscribe to get all our fun videos now
let's find out there 20 things you
didn't know about the boys of why don't
we
Jax acting background there's no doubt
that all of the members of why don't we
are super talented musicians but they
can do a lot more than just seeing Jack
Avery can play the piano and guitar and
he also writes songs back in 2015 Jack
starred in a short film called the
fearless 5 it's about a boy who becomes
a social media star and gets recruited
into a superhero force to protect
companies from bankruptcy it's only 7
minutes long and it starred Alex from
Target
Jack was a youtube star when he was cast
in this short how crazy is that where in
the world sometimes it seems like all
our favorite celebrities grew up near
Hollywood but thanks to YouTube it's a
lot easier for regular people from all
over the world to become famous though
why don't we boys are a real American
boy band they come from all over the
country
Jonah Marais is from way up north in
Minnesota
Zach Haren the band's youngest member is
from deep in the heart of Texas
Corbin Besson was born in Texas but grew
up in Virginia Jack Avery comes from
Pennsylvania and Daniel Seavey is from
Portland Oregon are one of the boys from
your state it's pretty cool that
together they represent so much of the
country
Jonah's solo album it's no secret that
most of the members of why don't we got
their start on social media there's a
ton of great talent on the internet
after all but did you know that Jonah
became so successful as a solo artist
that he released an album Jonah had a
huge following on the live stream site
you now when the daylight's gone is an
EP that was released on April 2nd 2016
it was really successful and helped
Jonah get even more famous before his
album Jonah performed as part of the
2014 digit or pretty major
accomplishment for someone so young
American Idol if you're like us you
probably recognize
several members of the band when you
first heard them after all they were all
independent stars when they formed the
band but do you remember where you
recognized Daniel CD from he was a
finalist on the 14th season of American
Idol back in 2015
Daniel made it to the top ten which is
such a cool accomplishment he was 9th
place when he was eliminated but he
gained a huge fanbase even though he
didn't win the whole season he is just
that talented Corbin's surgery back in
July 2018
Corbin tweeted that he had to have a
spontaneous surgery on his throat that's
how it's awful he had a huge infection
that was all swollen and blocking his
airway which made it really hard to
breathe he was in the hospital for a few
days but he made a full recovery he got
lots of love from his band members who
tweeted the sweetest well-wishes and he
got a ton of support from his fans -
we're so glad that Corbin was able to
get the surgery he needed and or extra
glad that it didn't affect his singing
voice Corbin is still going strong with
why don't we
Jonah's influence the members of why
don't we are all really young it's
pretty amazing that they have already
achieved so much Fame and success before
any of them even hit 20 years old so how
did these young guys know they wanted to
be singers it's always fun to find out
what inspired celebrities isn't it Fred
Jonah his inspiration came from Justin
Bieber when he was just 12 years old
Jonah went to a Bieber concert Bieber
was only about 15 at that time which
made Jonah realized he could do it -
Jonah totally worked hard to achieve
that dream it wasn't long after that
concert that he began posting videos and
getting a fanbase we think it's pretty
awesome that he's achieved his dreams so
young
ed Sheeran fans it's always fun to
remember that celebrities have favorite
singers - and sometimes they are lucky
enough to meet their idols all of the
why don't we boys agree on their biggest
idol Edie Sheeran jack has said that Ed
Sheeran inspired him to start playing
guitar and singing and just going for it
but they all agree that he is a
performer to admire they like to emulate
his vocals and they think he's just an
all-around amazing person they met
Sheeran at the 2017 Video Music
then they got to hang out with him
backstage at the 2017 Jingle Ball from I
heart media the nerd the why don't we
boys might be the epitome of cool to
their fans but even they have some
interest that people might think are
kind of nerdy Carbon is the
self-proclaimed nerd of the group he is
especially passionate about space outer
space he loves everything about the
universe from supernovas to black holes
to antimatter he even wears a NASA pin
given to him by his bandmate Daniel we
can't blame Corbin for being super into
space stuff we love that Corbin owns his
nerdiness there's nothing wrong with
being interested in cool stuff medical
mystery okay this next bit of trivia is
kind of gross but Zack can't burp yeah
we know weird he's never been able to
belch even as a baby he wasn't able to
do this one basic bodily function as a
baby his parents tried to get him to
burp but he couldn't now that he's older
his bandmates have tried to make him
belch they gave him a ton of soda but he
still couldn't do it so crazy musical
genius
American Idol finalist Daniel isn't just
an amazing vocalist he can play a lot of
instruments too we're not talking about
one or two he can play over 20
instruments he started playing the piano
when he was just four years old but he
quickly figured out that he can learn
new instruments by ear that is such a
rare talent how cool would it be to just
quickly learn a new instrument so out of
all of these instruments which is
Daniels favorite he says it's probably
the cello Rumi's we already know that
the voice of why don't we are total
friendship goals but aside from all the
time they spend together for their
careers they're also all roommates they
all bought a house together in Los
Angeles they're already always together
at the studio or for interviews and
stuff why not just live together
wouldn't you love to live with all your
besties we wonder if they ever get tired
of each other that's a lot of time to
spend together
big brother Jack has four sisters but he
is one awesome brother
his little sister Isla has always wanted
to go to Disney World
she started saving up money years ago
and after two years she's still didn't
quite have enough does
is expensive but once Jack started
making the big bucks with why don't we
he didn't go out and buy a whole bunch
of random junk
he took Isla to Disney World he posted
the sweetest Instagram post about it he
was so happy to be able to do something
for his sister Jack is just an awesome
guy international stars why don't we
have become popular all over the world
and earlier in 2018 they got to go on
their first world tour in the summer
they went on an Asian tour they
performed in Japan China Taiwan and more
they also went to Australia their
European tour began in October 2018 they
started in Spain and then Ireland
they're also going to the Netherlands
Germany and the United Kingdom in all
less than a month
that's a whirlwind of a tour and if you
want to see them in the United States
and Canada they start their next North
American tour in March 2019 have you
been able to see why don't we on tour
the Jingle Ball it's always a big deal
when newer bands get to go on a tour
with other really popular artists and
last year
why don't we got to perform on the same
stage as some really incredible singers
at the 2017 Jingle Ball tour why don't
we join some huge names they got to
perform with Taylor Swift
Demi Lovato Charlie puth even Fall Out
Boy was at a couple of the concerts I
hurt media does an awesome tour of
big-name stars at the holidays so it was
pretty cool that why don't we was
included those concerts had to be epic
AF boyband inspiration boy bands have
been around for a while they were really
big in the 1990s with Backstreet Boys
and NSYNC before that there was new kids
on the block but musical groups of all
male performers have been around for a
long time back in the 60s there were the
Beatles and the Monkees
so there's a lot of pressure to be a
successful boy band there are just so
many great ones in musical history
why don't we totally recognizes their
roots so which boy bands today aspire to
be like they really look up to the
musical geniuses of the Beatles and
NSYNC good choice boys they even have a
photo playing homage to the famous
Beatles Abbey Road shot social media
stars
pretty much a requirement to have social
media if you want to be a star nowadays
and we live for celebrity instagrams and
Twitter's but why don't we are
absolutely amazing at social media
within just nine months of being a band
their Instagram already had a million
followers bands used to have to really
wait for a big break to get that famous
they all had social-media followings
before they started to band which is
pretty awesome if you add up all their
followers now it's over 22 million band
name
why don't we is a super original name
for a band so where did they get the
idea from it literally comes from the
idea to start a band you know why don't
we start a band how did these five
musicians all decide to start a band
anyway well they all hung out in Los
Angeles they hit it off and said the
vibe was just there it felt right so
they decided why not and we are so glad
they did not only did they form an
amazing boy band but they gave us all
bromance and friendship goals to tattoo
goals these best friends and musicians
are very vocal about how much why don't
we has changed their lives they talked a
lot about how lucky they are to have
found so much success together in a
People magazine interview they were
asked if they would ever get matching
tattoos they said that they all want to
get a 1/5 tattoo on their wrist why that
fraction well they're all one-fifth of a
band and they know it takes all five to
make them great they think their wrist
would be cool because it would be
visible when they're holding their mics
last we heard they hadn't gotten the
tattoos yet we hope they do soon dating
fans part of being in a boy band means
tons of teen girls want to date them
it's nice to dream but it usually
doesn't happen
well don't worry ladies the boys of why
don't we said they would totally date a
fan if she was the right girl um so
you're saying there's a chance and what
makes the right girl in the same
interview they talked about how it all
comes down to personality and being able
to carry on a good conversation and it
helps to smell nice - keep dreaming
girls there's still a chance
two years we can't imagine a world
without why don't we it feels like we've
been fans of theirs forever but can you
believe it's only been about two years
the van was officially formed on
September 27 2016
that means they recently celebrated
their two-year anniversary in those two
years they've released several eps and
some amazing music videos we are so
excited to see what else comes from this
amazing band their fans known as the
lime lights are totally devoted to them
so who is your favorite member of why
don't we let us know in the comments and
there you go twenty fun facts about the
voice of why don't we be sure to give
this video a big thumbs up and don't
forget to subscribe
[Music]